dans le domaine artistique un autre
événement aujourd'hui cette fois avec le
lancement des transmusicales par
l'enfant du pays etienne daho
il a eu aujourd'hui l'occasion d'être
reçu en vie dans différents endroits et
il a plutôt été reçu comme un roi nous
l'avons suivi
12h aujourd'hui l'hôtel de ville de
rennes réception par le député maire
edmond hervé aime bien se considérer
comme un chef d'entreprise pour lui
etienne daho est un bon produit de
promotion pour sa ville je sait
l'attachement pour apporter à cette
ville et vous ne manquez jamais de la
rapée tous ceux qui depuis sept ans ram
comme des fous pour obtenir quelques
aides publiques dissimule à peine leur
satisfaction d'être ainsi reconnue cette
année le budget des transmusicales a
quintuplé 2 millions de francs en tout
dont 600 mille francs en subvention
municipale
etienne daho devant un échantillon de la
presse oui il est content de revenir à
rennes
oui il est content du succès des trans
oui il représente bien la modernité avec
quelques-uns qui joueront avec lui ce
soir
clin d'oeil avec les yéyés des années 60
françoise hardy est venu à rennes elle
aussi histoire de groupies
explique-t-elle vous allez chanter avec
les s'asseoir non j'aimerais bien la
nuit la nuit
j'ai fait un cauchemar et je me suis dit
que non je n'ai pas j'allais pas me
gâcher la vie pendant trois jours à
l'idée de chanter avec lui la face
visible des troncs ce dans toute la
ville la création artistique sa fiche
kiki picasso raconte à sa manière le
rock et noël par cette gigantesque
fresque l'ol et le rock c'est la fête
pour une ville et pour le monde entier
chaque fois qu'un grand événement rock
se prépare petit à petit en train de
devenir bien plus importants que moi
même d'ailleurs et je pense que le roc a
remplacé dieu depuis belle lurette plus
loin cette photo de richard dumas
visible d'une bonne partie du centre
ville
et puis cette décoration signée par le
couturier stéphane plassier lui aussi
est à rennais monté à paris pour la
première des transmusicales
il a réalisé cet ensemble néo réaliste